[Music]
you know Katy and Calvin have another
common bond that lady right there yes so
is Annie sending Taylor a message you
know he's being empowered vulnerable
strong those are words Katy uses to
describe her new album but what about
shade as in I am so getting back at
Taylor for dating one of my boyfriend's
before me and for writing bad blood
which everyone thinks is about me hey
can we talk about your new music yeah
the reason why I'm here you're not
disturb controversy all of my songs have
had meanings they've never been one
dimensional Katy tells aw there is no
one thing that's calling out any one
person so we'll take that as a no that
she's gonna take aim at Taylor
but then she confuses us a little saying
you can't mistake kindness for weakness
and don't come for me anyone honestly
when women come together and they decide
to unite this world is going to be a
better place um okay but then explain
this one while Taylor has been m.i.a not
seen in public since February while
she's working on her own new music katy
has gone and collaborated with Taylor's
ex Calvin Harris for his upcoming album
no word on who came up with that idea
these two men up backstage into 2013 MTV
Europe Music Awards and we're putting
money down that they've had at least one
very candid conversation about a tech
will do
I would love to have a transcript from
that conversation
[Music]
you